boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on sakyo and we
are still on site at the American
Anthropological Association Annual
Meeting we are now blessed to be sitting
down with dr. Graham press hello there
how you doing man I'm great how are you
thanks for coming on to the show thanks
so much for having me it's a pleasure
greatly appreciate it really excited to
be talking about what you care about
let's give a background on Graham Graham
is a PhD candidate at the University of
Washington he's working on the vehicle
residency project which we will be
unpacking tons of nuance really excited
about that and he's executive director
and co-founder at we count org check out
the link in the bio we'll be talking
about that as well it's a system that
helps communities request and donate
items for people in need
that need social services and it helps
with assisting homeless get off the
streets
Graham is also a National Science
Foundation graduate research fellow and
he also has a lot of very interesting
thoughts about applying practice
practical thinking to anthropology and
just in general I'm really excited to
break down your your your what you're
focused on right right now what you care
about but even before we get to that
let's talk about you and how you even
got here so who are you as a kid and how
did you get interested in anthropology
well let's see so I was a you know I I
grew up in that kind of you know
upper-middle class American suburbs here
actually in San Jose and I you know by
the time I was a as a youth I had
traveled a lot with my parents around
the country in an RV and my grandparents
were retiree snowbirds and and so you
know doing those frugal family trips you
know whatever we could was often in a
vehicle and then and then as I grew
older and became a punk rocker and sort
of often a kind of a contrarian with my
community around me I didn't feel like I
fit in a lot and so I you know I started
you know not doing as well in school
ended up failing out of high school
and actually became homeless at the age
of 15 lived on the streets of San Jose
Berkeley in San Francisco in parks and
under bridges and in vehicles if I was
lucky in a girlfriend's vehicle the time
or in the back of punk rock clubs where
I worked security often and and so I did
that's so I had experienced homelessness
and then and a after several months a
person at a community meal offered me a
quarter to help me to contact my parents
and that was the catalyst that helped me
to really you know connect with my
society and my future I was able to
retake my classes graduate from high
school but I had my son at 18 even even
after that and and wasn't you know able
to go to college or anything so I'm
actually sort of a late bloomer in a lot
of this I a lot of my work is based upon
real world applications because it's the
life I lived I having a son at 18 I
spent years in social service offices on
welfare getting medical coupons for the
birth of him or son and housing coupons
to keep housed and sheltered and I sort
of learned what it was like to stand in
lines waiting to get the assistance that
you need so desperately to survive and
so when it came to when I had the
opportunity to go to school myself in my
30s I was able to transfer into the
University of Washington I worked with
Jason de Leon who I believe you spoke
with earlier when as an undergraduate
and was able to actually go to field
school with him during the undocumented
migration project that was in 2010 so it
was early on in the in the project I
think was the second year of the field
school and when I came back from that
field school I was rip raring to go I
was you know really impassioned I knew I
wanted to do important work that was
compelling it was meaningful and that
for me had a deeper connection much like
Jason's work is with him and and so I I
had actually been bartending by this
point in community in Seattle known as
Ballard which is in North Seattle and
it's a traditionally blue-collar sort of
fishing and shipwright industry place
and I knew a lot of people who are
living in their vans and their RVs and
who you know I had had was serving in my
bar and they were you know I'd see them
sitting on the other side of
our day after day night after night and
I'd say you know and and then come to
learn that they lived in their vehicle
and it really challenged my own
preconceived notions around homelessness
based on my own experiences and what I
had seen em around me this was 20 years
later after I had experienced
homelessness so I had developed a lot of
the biases that many people have around
homelessness and and and I think that it
it was that challenging of my own
notions that pushed me to get into this
work so I started to get into vehicle
residency and distend and and research
be a Bruin see we could talk a little
bit more about that momentarily but uh
yeah that's that's pretty much how we
got there whoa
so it's crazy that you had a experience
yourself at fifteen of having to figure
out streets street life because that in
itself is a mmm that makes a man real
quick it I don't even know I you know I
would say there's a certain amount of
Arrested Development that comes from it
to you know to be not as I see a lot of
the world through my fifteen-year-old
eyes still and it's you know it's
difficult because it does I think it's
experiencing highly traumatic life
firsthand and secondarily that you see
when you're on the streets not just you
know from the experiences that you have
yourself but what you see around you
really it does have a lasting effect and
I think that for myself and many of the
people who I know who have also Beck's
perience homelessness it often leaves
this deeper kind of sense of passion
towards social and equality towards
under you know thinking about what it
means around identity and about
identities that are positioned on top of
people about you know when you spend
enough time on a street corner asking
for change and you see hundreds and
thousands of people walking by trying to
ignore you
it really does I think force a different
perspective on what it means to be a
member of our society to occupy public
space and to try to get by you know
and so I mean really I
that's that for me that was I think I'm
there I consider myself very privileged
for being able to have that experience
because it allows me to think about
those things at that sort of more
problematic way I can test the notion
even of what it means to be homeless you
know and and and that kind of they
versus we you know and I the way that I
see I've come to see this these these
experiences and social suffering is that
they are social experiences that things
that we all participate in that we all
experience we all feel from the cost of
that person the cost of the social
services from that person the cost of
reintegrating that person in society the
cost of the loss of productivity that
ultimately I see that for myself the
reason why I'm able to do this work was
because somebody reached out and offered
me a quarter and that small catalyst
that helped to make my change which is
part of the reason why we developed we
count as well is what brought my
potential back to the table and I think
about all the potential that we leave
off the table when we don't address how
we can help stabilize our neighbors and
how we can provide spaces for people to
connect with you know what's going to
help them to to be active parts of our
society
you have the quarter as a catalyst for
you to figure things out in your life is
crazy that the smallest sort of tiniest
butterfly effects kids exactly we can go
like that and then also when you're
talking about the the the the we the we
versus that them were the vase the us
versus the vase this the this is
something that we've had the chance to
talk about a little bit and even you
know before we get into the nuance of
the vehicle residency project just
speaking on that when you're on a when
you're on a corner and you're asking for
assistance you mentioned this earlier
there's a lot of these preconceived
beliefs and notions about what the
person who the person is why they're
there all this kind of stuff but
we've had the chance to sit down with
people on her show that lived on the
streets or we've talked to them on the
streets as well and a lot of times
they've had serious traumatic family
experiences that have led them to the
point yeah where their parents are
addicts or their parents aren't there
they live in multiple dozens of foster
homes along the way then they then
they're on the streets and that's where
they find family that's where they find
love
um and so why don't you tell us a bit
more about the we versus them thing as
well as the some of these preconceived
notions yeah you know I so I really like
Jason had mentioned in one of the panels
he was talking about about this idea a
Jason de Leon had mentioned as about
this this idea that when we talk about
migrant studies which is similar in the
work that I do that there's this this
this tendency to have to build up the
migrant as a human being and why don't
we just start with the assumption that
this is a human being and I tend to go
that route instead of saying let's show
that this person who's experiencing
homelessness is a real person why don't
we start by understanding that we're all
people and that we all make similar
choices based upon the options that we
see before us that there are many forces
of displacement of destabilization of
unsettlement right that that they can be
from our families they can be historical
economic forces they can be based on our
skin tone or a gender we call the
structural violence right all these
different ways that have these implicit
and explicit constraints on our ability
to produce healthy lives and and and I
think that the way that I like to think
about it is that if if we are all making
choices that we that are we perceive as
optimum within our environment of
options then that's very humanizing
right because why the person is sleeping
on the corner is a result of a response
to
environmental options which they
perceived before them right and that is
actually for me not only is it at base
humanizing because it is not they it is
we I'm a part of that environmental
option right that's where I when I talk
about the social suffering as a social
experience but it also I think is a way
that is empowering in that as a social
scientist and someone who's attempting a
sense of praxis of applying this and
just into practice is that I can affect
an environment right I can introduce new
options or work with policymakers to
affect the way options are provided to
people the choice is agentic right the
person is going to make this choice as
that as their own agent but we can offer
options that are more healthy and more
beneficial right and so I see that like
that seeing it in this way opens up new
opportunities to do good work right to
do transformative work and that by
limiting ourselves to this understanding
of they versus we right it allows us to
sort of offset that responsibility that
guilt that neoliberalism of saying this
person didn't play the game right so
it's their fault right when the reality
is we're all part of the game that one
of the things I often say is that you
know with there's this old saying of
we're all one paycheck away right from
homelessness I like to say no we're not
which the paycheck you get right now
right it is that it is the fact that we
are able to be successful and be able to
be healthy and live in the homes that we
have but not everybody has access to
that same level of level of resources
our paychecks are part of what makes our
lives great but they're not shared by
that other person out there too and so
it is the success that we have that has
a flip side of people who have have-nots
who have become have-nots and how do we
help to equalize that within our society
so that we can bring those people to the
table so that so that not only is that
that productivity from that person the
tax base from that person but truly that
those that intellectual work can be
brought back to the table and we can
actually grow as a as a human of the
human species from engaging all of us
yeah it's a really important way to look
at it it's it's looking at it from a the
systems thinking perspective or a
cybernetic perspective of that I am I am
Who I am and I have had the access to
what I've had and that has also had an
impact on what other people have access
to and what they have and so ok so walk
us through what happened from from from
going out into the field Jason de Lyonne
- onto realizing that you want to do the
vehicle residency project and yeah start
doing the work yeah so I so after
returning from the field with Jason like
I said I was rip-roarin and ready to go
and I knew I wanted to do work that was
compelling and meaningful excuse me and
and so I actually I purchased an RV and
I started actually living on the streets
of Seattle rather naively and I would do
it differently and if I was to do it
again mainly because one of the things I
quickly realized was that my experiences
were not the same as people who are
living on the street I had a home to
return to
and also that limited my understanding
of the vehicle as a home because since I
had this other place I called home the
vehicle was much more of a temporary
space whereas for you know people who
are living in the vehicle it was home
and that was really a significant
difference and it was one of the kind of
first insights into this whole sort of
assemblage of vehicle residency another
thing really quickly though that I did
see that was helpful was that I saw that
there was this tremendous amount of law
enforcement that was being applied that
not only of course you know the tickets
and the warnings you gotta move some
every 72 hours but that there was
signage everywhere I went that was
saying you can't park here and and it
was signage that that particularly
related to people living in vehicles so
I was finding that in these industrial
zones where that there was laws in
Seattle that I could only park my Rd in
industrial zones this is a really common
law that you can only park vehicles that
are over say 80 inches wide at the wheel
base in industrial zones
because you don't want those parking in
in residential streets for emergency
vehicles coming out in the middle of the
night right so you can only park those
vehicles industrial zones in the
nighttime right so between midnight and
5:00 a.m. I had to park my RV in
industrial zones just like every other
person in an RV and then in those zones
I saw the placement of no parking 2:00
to 5:00 a.m. signs right which you go
why do you where's the street sweeping
you know at 3:00 a.m. in the industrial
zone I mean it's just it's not there
those signs were put specifically to
remove vehicle residents from public
space and that that actually is what
what started the what drove my the
archaeological aspect of my research for
the the ethem archaeological aspect in
that I did three years of settlement
mapping and actually mapped where people
were parking vehicles and RVs trucks
fans and and cars on the streets and
correlating that with zoning parking
laws resources and showing how these
settlement patterns were being driven by
the constrained options that were
available within their environment and
how then that created densities within
the settlement patterns over time which
then led to further community complaints
which led to more no parking two to five
and signs which reduced the amount of
space and created more density right and
so I produced a report so during this
time I I worked for with Seattle
University leading the vehicle residency
research program and conducted two years
of that mapping with that program one
year as my undergraduate at University
of Washington for my honors thesis in
vehicle residency and and then presented
that report to the City of Seattle
helped to to lobby for the the creation
of a safe parking program that would
provide off street parking for people
living in vehicles i wrote the grant for
that program and we ended up start
developing in seattle back in 2012-2013
and i applied to become the outreach
provider for that program so that I
could continue my research through it
and from 2000 I think was 2013 2015 I
was the
the outreach specialist as it was called
for all vehicle residents in Seattle so
during that time for those two years I
worked at about 1500 people who were
living in vehicles all across the city
in Seattle I should probably say the
numbers what what we're looking at so in
Seattle there are roughly 12,000 people
who are experiencing homelessness about
half of those people are in some form of
emergency transitional or permanent
shelter so about 6,000 or in that about
the other the other 6,000 are in are on
the streets what are counted as
unsheltered of that unsheltered
population 53% are living in vehicles so
of the people on the street over half
are living in a car truck van or RV it's
3,300 people roughly across King County
and and yet there are virtually no
parking spaces for people in those
programs in any kind of emergency
services so that's why we developed the
safe parking program and and then I did
this research to help to kind of get a
better understanding of what the
on-the-ground experiences were for
people again because I knew that I there
was only so much I could get as sort of
audio ethnographic research from my own
occupation of the RV and so I wanted to
know more about what people were really
experiencing in their own lives so so
for two years I did that outreach work
afterwards I worked for the Social
Service oversight agency that's the HUD
mandated continuum of care oversight
agency as they're called which is called
haul home and I worked with them for two
years on their executive and governing
board and as chair of their policy
committee looking at how social service
policy and social services and policy
was being developed around vehicle
residency and I saw that well there was
abysmal Ino policies being developed I
shouldn't laugh it's it was horrible
there were almost no recognition of the
vehicle as a home and and because of
that because of this sort of what I have
come to term a nomadic pathology a view
of nomadic shelters as inherently sick
and wrong as diseased disease producing
an immoral that there's this criminality
and
and and filth or drug addiction all
these sorts of things that are built
into this that because we have that
settled societies have this tendency to
view these nomadic shelters this way
that they could not be viewed as
acceptable or appropriate and so
incorporating them into official
state-run emergency systems was almost
impossible and so that's what a lot of
my research has come to focus on is how
the this nomadic pathology dis
affiliates people from their society and
how it opens them to this
criminalization that is justified
because we see it as they shouldn't be
living in that vehicle in the first
place right and and for many people
there's this very important tension
between the vehicle as home and this
label of homelessness right and that the
the the label of homeless is a negative
identifier label that presents this
impossible barrier to overcome of how do
you become honed when you are homeless
by definition right and so for people
who are living in their vehicles who see
it as home not only does that not match
their identity but when social services
come in that are fourth quote the
homeless they say that's not me I don't
need your help so again you've got this
double problem of not only do you have
53% of the population who don't actually
have a parking space to connect into
services but they may not even want the
services offered because the way that
we're calling those services doesn't
match their identity right and this is
the kind of thing where simple changing
and our understanding of this can have a
massive effect right because
understanding that this is a that this
vehicle is an adaptive sheltering
strategy that this person is is using
this vehicle as what they perceive as
optimal shelter among a limited variety
of options right that these vehicles
have become affordable housing and that
in that case there's this this major
problem of what does that mean as more
and more people move into these vehicles
as affordable housing I think we'll get
to that more in a bit
but yeah that's not what I call the
nomadic turn Wow
so what a crazy kick-off to talking
about the vehicle residency project
because the way that the way that you're
talking about the systems that are in
place it just reminds me of our
conversations that we've had with people
and I so hard to even use the word
homeless again good and figure it out
the right nomenclature I may have heard
you say people experiencing homelessness
people experiencing homelessness better
I bet it is it's a it's an adjective
right homelessness is an adjective it's
not a label right we use it as an
identity as a noun right but the reality
is is that it's it's like I compared it
to driving a car when you're driving a
car you're a driver when you're not
driving a car you're not a driver that's
a good way to be so so people
experiencing homelessness exactly
because again these these new ways of
speaking about it are really important
especially in getting people the
services that they need
so this reminds me of our conversations
we've had with people who are
experiencing homelessness because
they're teaching us about all of the
aspects to the system that are causing
them the struggle of trying to get off
of the streets they are trying to get
off but there are so many variables that
are pressing them and you started
listing these these variables like if
you have more than an 80 inch wheelbase
then you can't park 12:00 to 5:00 but
then where you have to go to parked off
no parking from 2:00 to 5:00 a.m. so now
you also started kind of teaching us
that you know out of the 12,000 homeless
in Seattle people without homes in
Seattle that there are 6,000 of them in
sheltered residences and whatnot and
then there's six thousand that are that
are that are on the streets and 3,300 of
them are in vehicle residents so over
53%
of the ones on the streets are in
vehicles and there's no place for them
to actually to park their the vehicle
that they live in and so now you've made
this despair
that for them to actually be able to
park and and have their vehicle as their
residency in these in in spaces to
facilitate the proper because there is
no them this is all us and so we have to
figure that out and now as you're as you
know as you were speaking about that I
was thinking about New York and LA and
San Francisco and Chicago and all these
other places that have equivalent
numbers if not more than 12,000 people
living on the streets and that's a lot
of societal systemic change that I think
you are pioneering so okay so now now as
you're as you're doing this research you
you you went you had you had a thousand
five hundred people that you were
talking to on a daily basis about what
was going on in their lives what's up
there was a pool of fifteen hundred
people that I would be working with over
those two years but yeah pool of fifteen
hundred people that you were working
with over those two years talking to
learning about their diverse stories and
life trajectories and so now what were
you learning about their experiences
that was like holy crap we have to
change some of the things in our city
you know I would say that that that the
the main takeaways that I got that I
think we're really sort of revelatory
were first off and they shouldn't be I
should say they should not be revelatory
but they were for me and I and I hope
that they can be for others as well that
first off that these were people who
were displaced from their own
communities
that these weren't people who had come
to the city as a way to get their
resources that by and large the vast
majority of the people that I was
meeting not just people living in
vehicles also people in tents but
definitely among the people were in
vehicles were people that were from
Seattle or the surrounding area that
were using their vehicles as a way to
maintain their connections to their
familiar medical social
service systems right and that they used
these vehicles again as this affordable
housing to maintain this connection to
the city right and that what had
happened was that the over the previous
decades there had been a labor market
and technology shift in this in Seattle
which we experienced in San Francisco
and LA and other the main cities which
are experiencing the same problem or
same issue I should the challenge that
that there has been this labor market
shift and people who have the background
or the the privilege of education or
wealth to be able to move into that new
labor market of high tech and
information economy have been able to do
very well and been able to succeed in
that and this is where the it's our
paycheck now right but those who are
from the a blue-collar background or for
the many different reasons of structural
violence skin tone gender gender
identity even or and many more are
barred from getting into that new
economy and or from the educational
background to get into that economy or
employment background and so because of
that this shift has displaced this
population that people have the
gentrification the the gentrification
yeah that's when we look at it and it's
and but it's not just gentrification
it's I I always look at it at that
because when we think about it is
gentrification we respond with what we
need more affordable housing but I'd say
okay but affordable housing today is
unaffordable housing tomorrow if you
don't have a job yeah you could buy
would you call violence structural
impediments or the anthropologists call
it structural structural violence
provide social violence yeah and so that
structural violence is what holds people
back based on yes skin tones or it's the
isms
right you know the racism sexism you
know whatever you know ableism and that
that that the and it's it's really it's
the explicit and implicit biases that
that that are held that create
constraints on a pure person's ability
to have agency that is positive right
and often it constrains people to
choices
have negative outcomes right and so and
it's it's a it becomes a social
indicator of health right that
ultimately the person has there are
negative health outcomes that often
become from not being able to get into a
great job because of restrictions based
upon your skin tone for example so
displacement was a reoccurring yeah
theme that's right yeah so I had seen a
displacement occurring in Seattle and
people were were being they were unable
to as they were there was just large
rental base as the the rents were going
up because of the new economy people
were becoming addicted they were then
moving into their vehicles are moving
onto public streets often moving in the
street and then moving into a vehicle
because it was an optimum shelter and
and then because there was no place off
the street or in particular out of the
vehicle for a place to park the vehicle
and connect to emergency systems that
helped settle people and stabilize them
because there was no process to do that
this this this population just keeps
growing and growing and this is why
actually so even though we're at 53
percent this year vehicle residents are
53 percent of the unsheltered population
this year they have been actually 30 at
least thirty percent for the last ten
years and in the last ten years that
population because it's been rising I
should say they're thirty percent of the
unsheltered population in the last ten
years over that time the total vehicle
residency population has risen by three
hundred and eighty three percent so
we're talking about 2008 it was
something like around eight hundred
people and now it's 3,300 yeah and
that's been happening across major roads
that's right and that's was and that's
why I think that that that's the
takeaway here is that what we're seeing
is a response to internal displacement
and that again that people are turning
towards these vehicles as affordable
housing and which leads me to this
larger consideration sort of hypothesis
at the end of my dissertation of what
does that tell us about the nomadic turn
about this sort of this these individual
souls but the individual choices
becoming normalized into social trends
yeah right and and we even see this you
know obviously we
see at law in San Francisco I you know
there's a lot of RVs
in six guys shouldn't mention that as
part of my research I've done a I do a
critical discourse analysis where I look
at 500 articles about vehicle residency
all across the country for the last five
years looking at how this how we view
vehicle residency in our media and and
in particular about how much it's being
referred to as affordable housing and
how that trend is becoming more normal
in places like LA I'm not sure if you're
aware but they recently had to pass laws
where to restrict people from buying RVs
putting them on the street and renting
them as apartments because there were so
many people doing it and that is exactly
what I'm talking about right isn't that
what does it mean to our society to move
towards mobile housing as the new
version of shelter yeah right and there
are reasons why that's very pragmatic
right especially when you look at you
can move your house you can lose your
house and you look at things like that
you know these fires and in California
right now there's a lot of people right
now that have been displaced from these
fires that are living in their vehicles
and it makes perfect sense for them but
I think when you don't have to pay
fifteen hundred two thousand a month in
rent right but I think that we need to
take a step back and go back to why you
know looking at you know there is no
they we are we right that that the reef
we're all people and we're making
choices based upon the environment all
off the environmental options that we've
received before us then we need to look
at that person living in that vehicle
not as a good thing right we got to look
at it as this is the response to an
environmental set of options right and
that has possible benefits possible
detriment right it is not always just
progressive all right there's all this
you know march towards you know a future
of greatness right these things can be
good and bad and that and that that that
we need to see that vehicle as a
response to these larger social
environmental pressures that that may
have a larger destabilizing effect on
our society because we're honestly not
prepared for 3,000 RVs moving from city
to city yeah and you you're so
at the forefront of talking about this
in terms of it being a trend towards
mobile housing and you're also at the
forefront of talking about it in terms
of the it's all about us and not about
them type scenario because when you
think about it as a them type scenario
you're we're taking the blame and we're
moving it away from a society and we're
putting it onto the individuals that are
involved there but this is a this is a
direct effect of the economic and the
political pressures that we've that
we've created and that's why we see so
much displacement and towards this
mobile housing now within the mobile
housing there is a there's there is a
percentage of people that that have a
desire to be in a mobile housing there's
a percentage of people that are writers
or artists or full of philosophers or or
entrepreneurs in some ways that they
want to musicians they want themselves
to become with home instead of people
without home and so so then there's so
there's these categories of people that
are within the the people that are in
living in via and rest of vehicle
residences so that breakdown is also
really important to understand there are
actually people that are addicted to
really addictive drugs and also and that
that that desperately needs social
services to also assist in that sense so
that breakdown is also extremely
important to figure out and understand
and just hearing you talk about this
when I first heard you're talking about
this it's just so near and dear and
close to our hearts and in San Francisco
and our studios right on market and
seventh Street in downtown and so we
have a you know are we see so much right
there of
of not only people I'm living without a
home but also we see a lot of a vehicle
residents and we also see a lot of a lot
of the diversity of people living
without home like like I was just
describing that breakdown so what do you
what are your thoughts about that
breakdown of people and just give us
give us your thoughts about that
breakdown well I think you know I think
that I I would push back a little bit on
that I and and I would I would say that
it's not quite as hard and fast as that
and that and that we should getting back
to that whole there's no they we are all
we think that that people that that
there are many forces of displacement
they can be personal they can be social
they can be endemic there can be things
like you had a bad relationship with
your dad right so when I was homeless I
didn't get along with my family right I
ever came from a very privileged place
especially considering many other people
that I know and I was able to return to
that which is a tremendous sense of
privilege at the same time that what
moved me into that place of being
homeless was important for me important
for me enough to live on the streets
right and that was a force of
displacement now is it the same as other
forms of structural violence no there's
many different different reasons why
people get into this and I would add
that many of the many of the behaviors
that we that we observe among people who
are experiencing almost as such as drug
addiction or substance use as a whole
not only are they reflected throughout
our society and we don't ask the same
questions of the person who's in the
condo above the person who sit on the
street which is important right you know
but those just like that person in the
condo the people people use substances
as ways to manage and mitigate medicate
their traumas and you find when you work
with people experiencing homelessness
that many people experiencing almost
this did not use those substances before
they became homeless and they began
using those substances ways to mitigate
the traumas
experiencing so you know how do you go
to sleep at 3:00 a.m. when it's freezing
out while drinking yourself into
oblivion it's a lot easier okay how do
you stay up all nights with your stuff
because you're afraid of it well taking
a couple hits of something to stay up
all night is a good way to do it and and
that sort of behavior is done as a
response to the environment which again
what happens when you change the
environment all right so this is why
things like you know what I'm talking
about isn't it's not that like it's not
controversial this is this is what the
housing first model is based on this is
actually what HUD you know the the
Department of Housing and Urban
Development is is focused on right now
is trying to find ways to get people
into safe spaces immediately so then we
can remove them from the environmental
traumas that they experience on a daily
and nightly basis and start to actually
provide that stability that offers them
long-term development with with the
immediate relief and that's really what
I found in this research ultimately is
what do we need to do we need to look at
this as a two pronged issue and we
always focus on one or the other
and it's not that it has to be both
relief and development really it's a
relief portion is the integration of the
traumas in ways that are preventative of
people without homes I would say the
relief portion is providing a relief
from the trauma now yeah really
completely not immediately so that way
there is no trajectory that sends people
to being without home yeah or at least
at least helps it at least removes them
from the the the continuation of traumas
that they're currently experience
exactly so at least we can we can in a
sense you can never completely cease it
because a lot of trauma becomes
internalized but you can at least remove
people from the environmental traumas
that are experiencing around them yes
and because as I'm learning about this
more from you I'm seeing it as similar
to the pathologies that occur within the
body we've had so many brilliant
anti-aging scientists that we've sat
down with and whenever we talked to them
it's all about identifying the
pathologies before they start and then
that's how you can like tweak the body
over time to get healthy and since the
same exact thing is you're starting to
see
that this kid is having significant
trauma with his father and their there
is about to be a 15 year old on the
streets how can we intervene and prevent
that 15 year old from entering that
situation and so and so and so you also
make these points about substance
addictions they don't happen when
they're living in a home this happens
when you're trying to protect your stuff
or when you're trying to deal with the
freezing cold temperatures these
different situations so that's okay so
and then so then there's the there's the
relief and then there's the long term
development long term so then the
development is okay so then there's a
situation that we have right now with
vehicle residency's so how do you
develop a current place for vehicle
residences to go to but also develop a
city like Amazon's hq2 moving into Long
Island City and it's moving into Crystal
City
um in Virginia and so when you're when
you're looking at these two these two
cities that are in Nashville as well
where Amazon's moving into that that
there needs to be some sort of a a
promise a community promise of hey we
know that we're bringing so much
economic opportunity and development to
these areas and that's extremely
important for your cities but also we
know that we're gonna be causing
displacement and because we know we're
gonna cause displacement we're gonna do
a bunch of preventative measures like we
were talking about earlier that are
going to prevent that displacement from
occurring so that might be the
development that you're talking about
where you develop affordable housing
worth whatever what would well so so I
think of that when I talk about really
for development I'm talking about I
think I'm in a little bit different way
because I'm talking about it with people
who are currently experiencing
displacement the issue of Amazon is is
near and dear to my heart as someone
from Seattle doing research in Seattle
who moved to Seattle in 96 and when
Amazon before they really became big and
I worked in the.com boom and bust
alongside when Amazon was growing up as
well so
you know I know a lot of people work at
Amazon I've worked with Amazon many
times in the corporate and my nonprofit
does as well and so a lot of that is
what informs that idea of it's our
paycheck now right that that that
economic success we shouldn't demonize
that economic success because there's
obviously a lot of value that can come
along with it I think everybody should
pay their fair tariffs sir fair share of
taxes and be able to support our economy
as a whole but that's kind of a
different discussion but when it when it
comes to what those forces what forces a
company like Amazon can bring to bear in
terms of displacement on new cities I
saw it in Seattle I saw it for the last
20 years and I do know a pretty good
idea of what these other cities are
gonna be seeing and it is gonna be
massive displacement most like I
shouldn't say that there's the the the
history that we saw in Seattle tends to
show that there's a good chance that
you're gonna see similar things right
and then you're gonna see forces of
displacement because of again this
increased income base which then rises
drives up housing cost because of course
if you have the opportunity to charge
more you're gonna charge more of your
landlord and then the people who do not
have access to those jobs at Amazon or
the industries that surround Amazon
which you'll see pop up as well like we
did in Seattle are going to be priced
out of their market and that I think
that much like what we need to do in
Seattle we need to that that Amazon if
you want to look at how they're going to
protect against that displacement how
they can help to ensure that they won't
be bringing in structural violence into
these communities is that they need to
incorporate those communities into that
success and it's more than just bringing
in these jobs because they bring in the
jobs and they bring in the people to
fill those jobs they need to target the
communities themselves to fill those
jobs and that's why a lot of the work
that I do now with I am a member of the
I was appointed a couple months ago to
the mayor of Seattle's innovation
Advisory Council and a lot of the work
that I'm doing there is pushing towards
a an integration of
rapid rehousing of like the programs
that provide subsidized housing for up
to a year along with Europe training
programs at these top 10% of our
employers so that what we can actually
do is is ways to integrate people who
have been displaced into the businesses
that are causing the displacement right
because that's actually that's how we
solve this problem of affordable housing
it's not affordable if you don't have a
job right we need to get people the jobs
but you also need the immediate relief
so that's relief and development right
get a house right now and provide people
the skill set yes to be able to afford
that house a year from now and that
right there is not new that's the New
Deal I was just about so there there
were there were three million people two
million I did them I checked you checked
I check us to it okay no you know so so
there was a period of time where there
right now we're looking at about 350 or
400 thousand homeless people in the
United States experiencing almost sorry
we're trying to change the new picture
yes so for people experiencing
homelessness 80 years ago and this was
around 1935 and the New Deal was tell us
about how that took two million people
right and helped those people without
homes right stabilized yeah yeah and
settle in their communities yes really
the point settle into the community is
that uh I don't even take a step back if
you look at where that population came
from it was originally it was from
forces of displacement that go all the
way back to the founding of the United
States I mean it was some of the some of
these people were indigenous populations
originally some of them were poor whites
poor non-whites poor people of all
different backgrounds who have been
displaced who faced these similar issues
of evictions of rental costs and and
became this this basic massive poor
underclass of our society and
particularly the civil war was there was
very distress upon this this grew the
the destruction of the lands of the
farms people's you know people would go
off to war and their bean
we're to return to north and south and
so at the end of the Civil War this
little brief history those soldiers were
brought back to New York so that they
could be cleared out through the train
lines the new train line since they
brought everybody back to say ok you're
no longer north and south we're back
together we're gonna clear you out from
being a soldier and send you home they
put them on railroads out of Hoboken and
those became the hobos and that's
actually where that term comes from
originally is from these hobo armies
that were initially immobilized as it
responds
a clearance of soldiers from the Civil
War and those soldiers had no homes to
return Tuesday started on the road and
they started looking for jobs where they
could and again the same time you had a
technological shift of this turn towards
industrialized farming right and so as
we have this move towards industrialized
farming a lot of the farms that were
subsistence farms that had been before
we're getting brought up in a larger
plantations with you know in the south
they were you know using sharecropping
and in the north and in the West we had
these large you know fields and
everything those all of that was then
was the the hobo became this workforce
that were moving across the country as
the labor market shifted into
industrialized mining and industrialized
timber that force moved with it to
become the workforce that moved into the
West right and into places like Seattle
where they work to become part of the
the lumber industry and and James
Bradley who did a lot of this work wrote
his book you owe yourself a dorama draw
your self a drunk about tramps talks a
lot about that about how this sort of
this rise of this this population and
then what happened was is that by the
the 1930s as you mentioned 1920s there
were around 2 million people who were
experiencing homelessness in this night
in the country the United States and
they were a you know colloquially called
the [ __ ] and hobo armies moving from
city to city and and what's interesting
is that the the initial response to that
to help to stabilize that group many of
us forget but it was actually called the
transient service and I think it's
important that with that that we you
know take a moment to think about what
that term means
because at that stage the social service
providers saw that what was needed was
stability was settlement that there was
this movement this this mobility this
migration of people that was the issue
right and that if people could be
settled in the place where they were
then they could be revived that
development that's the relief and the
development and so at that time there
was this growth of these places called
Hoovervilles which we've all probably
heard of and we often see these pictures
of these places as these massive sources
of urban blight the one in Seattle is
one of the most famous there's this real
famous picture of the the Seattle
Hooverville and but what we don't know
or we've forgotten is that those were
places of settlement that those were
places where people were finally allowed
to settle down and the government came
in with social services and brought in
educational programs child care programs
job retraining programs and that those
were what became eventually the New Deal
with its rights and wrongs I viously
freely admit that they're not New Deal
is by no means perfect and in enforced
its own systems of structural violence
and with redlining and and other very
problematic things but one of the things
that it definitely did right was that it
it said that what we needed to do was to
not only provide these people with a
space where they could be now but we
need to provide them with the skills to
build out the economy to build out their
new cities so we employ settlement and
skills settlement skills relief and
development yeah and so what we did was
is that we employed that population to
build things like the Hoover Dam so that
suddenly now these people are laying
concrete and they're pipe fitting and
they're putting in electrical lines
well those skills is what they then used
once everything was done to ship that
person off to Ohio to build out their
own little town and right now we could
potentially use coders or designers or
corporations that's right and at a time
when we have record unemployment
specifically for that market because
much of the people who are on who are
unemployed but have fallen off that
roster as we know which skews our
unemployment numbers those are people
who don't necessarily have access to get
into that high tech jobs in the high
tech jobs we have record on employment
we need more people in those jobs those
industries are hiring like bad yeah and
they're looking for people that they can
help to sort of mold into the positions
that they that they're looking for
absolutely and we have this population
who desperately want to settle down who
want a safe place to be want to fit in
what there's there our society right and
and really see this as home that this is
still their home and yet they're being
moved out from their home own homes
because these new industries have come
in so going back to the Amazon
discussion right that this is what
Amazon I in my opinion needs to do to
help to address that in places in New
York and in DC is in Crystal City is
that we need to first off incorporate
the people who do not historically have
the access to those jobs into the hiring
practices to get them into those jobs
that's first off how we a stress is on a
structural level right and then for the
people who will become displaced we need
to actually funnel that population
directly into those jobs as well so I
think that it needs to be sort of
twofold that there needs to be an
initial approach of how do we hire local
populations to work at these incoming
industries yeah so we don't displace
them yeah and then if there is
displacement which often there is and we
see that we need to specifically focus
our social services to hiring people
into those programs and we have these
services already I mean it's work force
I mean it's it's labor force I mean
these systems and the private and public
market the federal government's been
running job retraining systems for
decades right and and we you know it's
it's not a radical idea you know it's a
it's it's a matter of believing that
there is not a deserving and undeserving
population that we are all we and that
by supporting that group that we are
helping our total society and that not
that that that person just needs to be
pushed away and we need to focus on the
good ones right and that's really what
we seem to have been doing and it's
causing a lot of a lot of
destabilization yeah yeah
the
the vision of seeing tech giant using
its abilities resources to bring people
that are without a home in for with
social workers and with coders to
retrain I think can happen within within
a year I do think that you very much so
could happen and I was just I was just
just envisioning what that would look
like and it was really cool to think
about but it's very very difficult to
repattern
someone's habits in their cognition to
desire to code or design or do ops it is
just it's not impossible it's just
difficult and so but it's but well I
would agree and I think that that that
machine this is I want to touch back on
your your initial question about sort of
the varieties of nomadism maybe we could
say right that sort of that idea of
wanderlust the person who inherently
driven towards moving and and displace
people who are who are migratory by the
imperatives of their environment as
sister Louise would say the I think that
that first off that that that by by
providing these skill sets you know the
person may not take that job at Amazon
but now they have that skill set to be
able to take it elsewhere
right so that's the same that's really
what the Hoover Dam was doing it was no
that was not about getting them to this
job but it was getting them this skill
string yeah right yeah so first off
there's a lot of potential even if the
person doesn't get hired in that one
thing but there's also this the in
studies of nomadism this is why a lot of
my research actually looks at this as a
version of nomadism and this idea of
what it means to set and to rise that
when people are pushed into movement by
these destabilizing forces of
displacement that have been going on for
thousands of years that when people are
mobilized
and Anna and Maine and and live within
these persistent consistent
destabilizing environments that say
you're not allowed here you got to keep
moving it's environmental pressures or
social pressures or economic pressures
but that that thing that says keep
moving along that that people Nomad eyes
right they normalize to this migratory
behavior because that's all they've come
to know right it becomes normative right
and and that versus the settlement and
skills well and I would say that that
these people were raised in a settled
society yes people are raised with the
sedentary ideals that I have and I'm
sure you do as well that that the
success that we can achieve in our lives
is based upon settled life right that
having a job having kids putting clothes
you know hosing your kids food on your
table having a good education all those
things are done by hat being settled
down right and then we did we teach
ourselves that's what Robby move a calls
to set interest to Gemma D right and
then what he says that the flip side of
that is this anti nomadism that says
that anything that's nomadic is bad
right and and so when a person becomes
nomad eyes and becomes used to being
sort of this being treated as a social
other as being pushed off on society
never really able to settle down
of course one would normalize that as
that's just how life is
because that's all you see everywhere
now the flip side of that is is that it
takes time to normalize it also takes
time to set in her eyes that being able
to wrap your head around what it means
to live a settled life it takes effort
and it takes work on the person involved
but also on people who are working with
them right and so I always like to think
of it like this Center ization comes
from giving someone a couch in a TV when
you put someone on the couch and put a
big-screen TV and they get to sit there
and watch that and after a while ago man
I really like watching this TV what do I
gotta do to have that TV well I got to
have a job gotta have a house that's
senator is Asian it's when the person
internalizes these ideas that they
want to have that settled life right
well if you only see the options
available around you that say you must
have a nomadic life that's all you ever
know that's what you see is right right
this is what I'm saying so it's about
augmenting the lens of both the settled
society to see that there is a nomadic
society that does not know that there is
a settled society and also to augment
the lens of the pneumatic society to say
that there is a settled society where
you can find more of a comfort and
stability and a potentially a meaning
from doing something fulfilling everyday
that is that isn't driven towards value
but I I think it's I think that it's
more of I like I like the way you put
that but I think that is more of a it's
about yeah I think that it's the work is
more on what we need to do with the
settled society it's more about you
telling the settled society that you
know this person doesn't want to be a
nomad mm-hmm yeah that's that's right
and on the other side the thing is is
that once that work allows to space for
that person who has been treated as a
nomad to settle down right and that
becomes that relief and development all
these other issues of wanderlust right
why doesn't the person want to settle
why don't they feel engaged in their
society right I mean why did Thoreau go
to Walden right right because you didn't
feel you needed to go somewhere else
right and didn't feel that this was
right in that place maybe that is that
it is that a migrant is that a homeless
person is that no it's a person who's
moving in their life to find new things
we all do that right so if you look at
why do we do that we can start to
understand this better if we look at the
you know the the trust fund kid who's
traveling across the country with the
surfboards in his RV or van hey that's
awesome man and and it but it's I don't
think there is a difference in that
that's vehicle residency that's
displacement it's a different force of
displacement just like my force that
drove me into homelessness was a
different force than many other people
experience right but but but by by kind
of splitting hairs over that
we we get lost in the weeds and we lose
the fact that it's about how do we find
ways to to settle people yeah you know
you settled ourselves this entire
section of our conversation has so much
for me to do with what is today's new
deal like a really powerful new version
to of what a new deal was because the
350 to 400 thousand people that are
currently without home a vast majority
of them would want a settled it's
exactly right and so we and they want to
settle in our cities to I think that's
an important piece is that we often
think about this as all but we have all
this fast farmland in the Midwest if we
just move people out that you go well
these are people who lived in the city
before why are we moving them from the
city why does somebody else get the
right to the city and and the people who
don't have this new economy accessing
the economy suddenly lose access to the
city that's not right that's right and I
want to touch on this because this is
something that you've been working on
now he co-founded it and the executive
director of we count so teach us about
we count so we count directly came from
this research and my experiences with
homelessness touching back on that story
of the person who gave me the quarter
you know I I was trying to think about
how do how do we empower the public to
be the provider of that quarter to all
the little needs the 15 year old me's
around the world right and or everybody
else not me but but that but that and I
saw myself in that in and and and how do
we use that as a way to connect people
to to become that catalyst to connect
people to services that can help to
settle them and and so we developed we
count it's a it's a website first off
it's not an app specifically so that
people can use it in libraries and
social service sites so that we could
have low barrier access low very entry
into that system we the system was
actually originally based upon the ideas
of Marcel Mauss from the gift so again
it's very deeply saturd in anthropology
oh gee in that one of the kind of well
there's lots of stuff that the mouse
talks about but one of the main sort of
takeaways is that there's three aspects
of giving that are sort of universal you
have a giver a receiver and then this
act of reciprocation and that if you
don't have that reciprocation you really
don't see a repetition of the act of
giving right because there needs to be
this thank you or maybe it's a grace
from God or maybe it's actual repayment
maybe I get a gift back there's all
these different ways that we do
reciprocation but if my ologies so yes
that all true you right you're exactly
you're not gonna want to be involved in
the in the future and so looking at that
it was okay so we we know what a giver
would be that would be the donor the
donating public we know what the
receiver would be that would be the
person requesting this item but how do
we do that as that reciprocation and so
we really we started the whole project
off actually the first six months before
we built anything or designed anything
we interviewed people experiencing
homelessness we interviewed social
service providers executive directors of
nonprofits public policy makers you know
Human Service Division people all
throughout Seattle to understand what
was needed and what we heard over and
over again was people saying look don't
reinvent the wheel don't create a new
service we got a lot of social services
and we don't have the funding from all
residents right
what we need is is a way to bring people
back to the well right to keep keep
people connected this idea of you know
you can lead a horse to water but you
can't make them drink well you leave the
horse to water enough times it's a good
chance it's gonna drink right and and
that's and I don't mean to talk about
people's other animals any sense but you
know that that the the analogy or
metaphor hole total net in that you know
we provide the carrot don't bring the
person to the water to drink at all I'll
send you a video afterwards so you can
you can use if you're interesting you
show yeah
but basically what the system does is a
person can request an item they actually
they request it from the Amazon
Marketplace so we again activate their
sense of agency and that they can
request really anything they want the
restrictions are you know no weapons no
combustible materials
or liquids no food because you can't
ship that through safely and there's
there's issues around that but beyond
that it's the the socks and on well
socks underwear tents backpacks it's all
items that are under $50 but it also
could be a hot plate it could be a cell
phone it could be a tablet PC right and
there are them there are tablets under
$50 and so in or boots right and so you
know we we opened it to to really allow
the person to search you can do it as a
search bar you search through the Amazon
Marketplace whatever you want and you'll
see this endless listing of these things
and it's the same information you'd see
on Amazon but you don't see the price
right and so the person go through and
they can choose what size boots what
color boots they then request that item
when they request the item the first
time we present them with what's called
a needs assessment questionnaire so it
asks questions like are you looking for
housing are you a veteran are you
traveling with kits it's all
confidential and it's securely held um
but so we ask these these basic
questions about what their needs might
be
and then we suggest social service
locations to pick up their item a
donation that actually match their needs
so then when you go on the site and
there's a one set kind of site of this
one version of the site or one side of
the site is for asking for items the
other side is for donating items and so
when you go into the donate side you see
the request from the person we use
avatars instead of pictures to avoid
implicit bias because some people don't
want to go you know give to people who
don't look like them common form of
implicit bias and so we do that person
can can tell a little bit about their
story a little bit about you know
provide a little bio about themselves
and then and why they're asking for this
item if they want to they don't have to
and then we have the item listed and so
then the donor can go in and purchase
the item directly through Amazon through
a secured payment processor and the item
is then shipped directly to the location
to connect the person with social
services and needs through and then we
provide the reciprocation at the end
where we send the donor information
about thank you for donating your
backpack - Jimmy you connected Jimmy
with housing and Veterans Services boom
yeah yeah
I love the
aspect of of anonymity but also of its
like it's a not it's in it's not fully
anonymous but it's just exactly it's
just it's just enough anonymous to not
have bias and then it's also getting
them what they need getting them to a
social service location and offering
them the resources that they need to
help them get off the find a home if
they so desire to and you're pulling
them to figure out the rights of service
protection to send them to it's really
powerful
check it out with links in the bio for
weekend or give it a look and we're
should we're in the middle of upgrading
the site right now so if you go there I
don't know when this will air but you
may see an under-construction but we're
actually talking with some major I
shouldn't mention the names but major
social media players which you are very
much familiar with about ways to
integrate this into their platform great
and actually so imagine you were on some
of these social media platforms and you
actually saw a request from your local
neighbors that's a $20 back right and
you can donate it right there through
that yeah that's fantastic and that's
gonna be huge for helping people and
then they have to go to a social
services center nearby to pick up the
backpack and and it against it
we've talked I've a couple times we use
this word this term push right of
pushing people into stuff and I really
like to think the other way pull yeah
that really what we're doing is is that
and this comes again from my research
with vehicle residents so often I see
people being pushed around communities
literally and that doesn't solve
anything it removes people's agency
removes people's resources like the
displacement and battle is its place as
a whole is the insult is the settlement
that's right that's exactly right and so
what we're trying to do is create polls
into our systems to help keep people
connected that's right and there's
another there's a there's there's this
word that we're all familiar with the
word is genius oh and we were talking
about this a couple nights ago and I
really enjoyed your definition of genius
one who inspires another two great
thought so it's not necessarily about an
end
that is a genius but it's more so about
that individual that knows how to
inspire others to this great source of
potential for themselves that's right
that's right the collective so yeah tell
us a bit about that because it's so cool
yeah so it's it's I mean it's it's it's
not my definition this is the original
Greek definition actually and so it's it
it's the the original weave the the
common kind of understanding of genius
as you said is it's generally some
single person who's very abnormally
gifted and intelligence maybe might be a
working definition I don't know but
something along those lines but it's
generally an individual who's very smart
in some way but but the Greek definition
was much more like a muse and that a
muse is a thing or a person or an entity
of some sort that inspires an artist
towards producing great art that is the
same thing for a genius and actually if
you look at the origin the word genus
genus means origins right and so it
becomes this origin right and so it is
it is genius is the that which inspires
people to producing these great thoughts
and I love I love that idea because it's
it's much more I think of it as a
democracy of intellect right the idea
that that we all have within us the the
potential towards great thought that it
is genius is our people like Jason de
Leon I I consider him a genius that you
know that in my experience is working
with Jason he absolutely inspired me to
think more deeply about my world and and
to be much more critical and and you
know I there is absolutely no way that I
would be doing my research had I not
learned that sense of critical thinking
and the skills that I learned from him
and other anthropologists who I
considered genius is a Rachel Chapman
Miriam Kahn
my spend Hawkinson my dissertation chair
Danny Hoffman and all these amazing
people I've been able to work with Holly
Barker who who show that anthropology
can be more than just theory it can be
practice which is the other thing we
were talking about yes yes leads us into
practice please yeah that we can bridge
this gap between sort of this
navel-gazing staring down our noses
anthropologists out the world and get to
a place where our work actually is
affecting the world around us because
it's anthropologists generally care
right that's why we get into this work
hopefully you know that we do it because
we're we're passionate about humanity
and about the world around us and why we
do the things we do and the history of
the discipline has really been much more
of this sort of extractive model of
going in and and finding these places to
pull the data out which then we make
into our careers and and that doesn't
sit very well with me and Anna and a lot
others too I think there are a lot of us
who come from places of various forms of
inequality and various forms of
privilege and look upon them reflexively
say you know what I've been there on
both sides and what can that and then
take that as a sense of responsibility
right for me I feel a responsibility
towards social structural change I I
feel like for that 15 year old me and
the 1,500 people that I worked with in
vehicles and my friends who are living
in vehicles now that if if I am not
doing work that is applying my theory to
actually create large-scale structural
change that I'm not doing enough work
right that's hard that's it's it's
probably it may be too much pressures
and I put up myself in that regard but
but it's powerful
it drives me you know and I and I'm not
alone in that you know I think that's
that's where that's where a lot of
entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley are
pushed towards actually executing
an idea rather than just talking about
that's right and and I think I know to
be honest I think that that's the future
of our of our discipline of anthropology
of the four field and of the four fields
of anthropology and as ethnologist I
think in particular archaeology has this
amazing potential yeah to to do this
work through analogy and and in ways
that that sort of twist our minds around
and make us think in whole new ways
about what we see in front of us what
we've seen all our lives one of my
favorite this is definitely gets into
practice but one of my favorite quotes
around this is from William Rath she who
was one of the founders of sort of or
one of the people who helped popularize
after archaeology through his garbology
work and encourage you to look more into
that's very interesting garbology
garbology actually he so so wrath wrath
she went out and looked at these federal
statistics and surveys that have been
being done for a hundred years about by
the FDA about and USDA about food
consumption patterns and and and trash
disposal patterns right and then he
would go in and excavate in that local
dump down to that year and find out what
people were actually disposing of and in
that way what he what he says is is that
our lives consists of these two versions
of reality of a mental reality of what
we think is happening and we're just so
sure that's real and then the material
reality which is the actual stuff that
we're depositing in the earth yes right
and that we can compare those and bring
those realities together to create this
more holistic version yes that is actual
reality there's truth and and and that's
what I try to do with my work of looking
at this mental reality of what does
vehicle residency look like how do we as
a society look at it and what are the
physical realities of actually living in
this conditions and how does that shape
by our social services and all this kind
of stuff and and that in my mind that's
that being able to tie a current reality
of persons living in a vehicle to past
realities of mobile sheltering things
like the Irish travelers the tinkers
Roma
quote gypsies as they're sometimes
referred and I would
mentioned to your audience it that is a
racial epithet which many people push
back at and encourage people not to use
the word gypsy and and and even on that
note it's often used for cultures all
across the world really and it's really
just about mobility it again gets back
to that nomadic pathology it's a way to
label someone as the nomad and it's the
outsider that that those sorts of things
that looking at that that in other
cultures and in our own past can tell us
about what we're seeing now that what
what my sense what my anthropology is
taught taught me so far and this
practice is that vehicle residency as we
see it if we compare it to past nomadic
cultures or so-called nomadic cultures
we see that that in this internal
disabled ization the internal
destabilization and this social other
ring creates these in these kind of
persistent environments of this of these
constraints can actually create
internally separated cultures so that
these cultures become distinct from the
their neighbors around them because
they're so socially isolated yeah that
they're just constantly pushed out and
the Irish travelers are a great example
for five hundred years this was pushed
and pushed and pushed until actually
last year they I don't know if you're
familiar this but there was a they had a
genetic test done that showed that that
they were able to officially show that
they were genetically distinct from the
rest Irish people even though they were
descended from them all right so that's
kind of interesting to think about like
that that 500 years of socialized social
isolation and intermarriage because of
that social isolation of course they
created this you know arguably
genetically distinct population and and
I threw analogy look at that and say
what does that tell us about what we're
seeing right now right that what we are
seeing right now I believe is that
initial dispossession point it's that
origin story of how the Irish travelers
became the travelers right it is that
it's evictions it's changes in labor
markets it's people being unable to
afford the ability to stay in the city
and then they become displaced and live
on the sides of the roads right and then
the technology
shift and they move from being a tent
into a vehicle because it's a lot better
option right and that's what we're
seeing now and and and it's I think that
it's something that again from at that
practice look that that thinking about
what that that may tell us about our
lived reality is is something that we
should be really concerned about as a
society I you know there's this idea
that that nomadic nomadic behaviors are
an existential threat to settled life
and I think there's some truth in that
in that that nomadic life needs this
open non bordered world so they can move
so people can move throughout that world
to collect the resources they need when
they need them because because it's a
non extractive form it's it's what's
what and it totally cause enough you're
called a color of productive form that
he said that it was it was that nomadism
is is saying there's not food here so I
got to go over there to produce it right
to find new forms whereas the settled
world extracts it from that thing rain
so so if we are living in this subtle
world of this extractive form and people
are moving towards this nomadic form
that means that you have a group of
people that no longer see borders that
people that move freely places to be
able to get move have to move widely to
be able to get the resources they need
and become even more further
destabilized by that and if we actually
you know sort of operationalize that
what does that mean in reality to now
you're talking you know three thousand
RVs moving city to city right our
country is not prepared for that the
United States doesn't have the
infrastructure we don't have the social
services developed for that and arguably
I would say that you know that that as
I've already shown in my research so far
that sort of thing perpetuates itself
and becomes more and more more and if we
go down that route its leads to further
instability so this is where I really
think we need to
head that off at the pass we need to
really focus on how can we find ways to
settle this population to stabilize this
population before we are looking at this
new American traveler you know and yeah
yeah that was such a good synthesis of
what we talked about in your research I
feel very enlightened about what's going
on in the world and especially in the
United States I feel very enlightened
about what's happened in throughout the
history of nomadic people and I feel as
though it is in some ways that is it's a
desperate time that and we need to put
the measures together to prevent further
displacement and to put together the the
relief and development settlement skills
that are needed to to solve this and and
get drop drop to them in the day and get
to the we in the US yeah yeah it's it's
such a pleasure talking to you about all
this Graham and if I could enter a
positive note on that I think that there
that there is a positivity in all this I
think that that we need that we can see
that these changes what is a learning
experience and there's things that we
can take from this but that even beyond
that I really love this idea of creative
destruction of make you know doing rid
of getting rid of what's not working to
make space you use those resources to
build up what is working I don't know if
you know that the story of 3m right of
them using that every year they go and
they take 15% of their products off the
line right and they take no matter what
they take 15% and they take all that
money and they put it an RD to build up
what is working even better mmm right
and I like to think of that these sorts
of moments of crisis that we experience
of change are opportunities for us to
reimagine the future right these are
breaking points where we actually have
an opportunity to break from the past to
say you know we are not cursed to relive
the lives of our ancestors we are not we
do not need to build futures on our Rand
father's bones right we can build a new
reality and we can learn from these
things to have a world that is more
equitable
that that that that has processes that
don't create these inequalities imagine
if we took that 3m model and we applied
it to everything in life to 15% of
things that aren't working in
civilization and invest that into
fifteen percent into R&D for what is
working in civilization and keep them
moving the ball for a better yeah I
think we do a good amount of that right
now but but we definitely need to think
about that more often as as an integral
part of of what we do because I think
there is a tremendous amount of
complacency at times the way things are
and I think it's very interesting that
entrepreneurs or artists or people that
are just basically unsatisfied with the
current paradigm of the world are the
ones that go like nah we got to change
that [ __ ]
and they are the ones that go into some
build it and do it and that's why we
love talking to people like you to
people that are building the future and
talking about the important research
that you're doing in and you know I
really recommend everybody to take a
look at Graham's work check it out in
the bio also check out we count org much
love everyone thank you so much for
tuning in Graham thanks for joining us
on the show thank you so much super fun
it was awesome yeah really great meeting
I've loved our conversations me too yeah
I'm so happy with Knights go absolutely
and everyone check out the work also
give us your comments we'd love to hear
from you in the comments below let us
know what you think about the episode go
and do your own investigations into
vehicle resident season engine people
that are without home and go and talk to
them go check out our episodes that
we've done on street life the foreign
street smarts going to check out those
episodes and see what we're talking
about and talk with the service
providers and how you can help them yeah
I talked to service providers how you
can help them pass a little past some of
your time actually going in volunteering
time to to these efforts to humanize
ourselves and also go and manifest your
dreams into the world build the future
thanks to triple-a the American
Anthropological Association is annual
meeting this has been super fun down in
San Jose thanks everyone and much love
see you soon peace that's great Wow man
love it yeah really a lot of fun that